التطورات الميدانيه المتلاحقه في الساعات
الماضيه في مختلف الجبهات فعلى اطرافه
مدينه باخموت لا تزال المعارك مستمره في
اتجاه سوليدار وهذه المنطقه تتركز فيها
قوات الاوكرانيه بشكل متزايد وتلقى مزيد
من التعزيزات العسكريه مدينه دونتسك عاصمه
المقاطعه
شهدت قصفا اوكرانيا بقذائف المدفعيه على
اثنين من احيائها ادى الى اضرار في البنيه
التحتيه وفق عمده المقاطعه الموالي لروسيا
اما في المقاطعه نفسها وتحديدا باتجاه
مدينه ليمن فقال الجيش الروسي انه صدى عده
هجمات للقوات الاوكرانيه ودمر دبابات
ومدرعات ومستودعات للذخيره
في مقاطعه
بالجنوب استهدفت القوات الاوكرانيه بالقصف
13 موقعا للقوات الروسيه وتسعه مرابض
مدفعيه